字幕: Yuki Kato
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さん こんにちは
（観客）こんにちは
（小野）こんにちは
今日 私が伝えたいことは
「答えのない問い」に
取り組みましょうということなんです
なんで 「答えのない問い」に取り組むことが
大事なんでしょうか？
「答えのある問い」と
比べて考えてみたいと思います
「答えのある問い」というのは
私達が長年経験してきた
受験勉強のようなものです
私達は 答えを知っているような問いについて
取り組んできました
一方で「答えがない問い」というのは
研究のようなものです
研究で私達は 未だ発見されていないことや
まだわからないこと
答えのないものについて取り組みますよね
研究のプロセスの中で
私達は 人と出会い
話を聞き 資料を集めたり
更には 自分の情報を発信するために
プレゼンテーションを行ったりします
実社会でも 例えば 新企画の提案を
しなければならないといったときには
それは「答えのない問い」への挑戦と
同じようなことではないでしょうか？
ですから 皆さんも 積極的に
「答えのない問い」に
チャレンジしてください と
言いたいわけなんですが
現状はどうでしょう？
私は大学に入って ある講義で
教授が私達に
「君は大学１回生ではない　高校４年生だ」
と言われたことを思い出します
たしかに そうかもしれません
本来 大学というのは
研究機関で「答えのない問い」を
探し求める所のはずなんです
しかし 私達は まだ
高校で培ってきた 受験のための勉強
すなわち 「答えのある問い」への勉強から
抜け出せていないのかもしれません
だからこそ 今日 私は
「答えのない問い」に取り組む楽しさと
そして その重要性を話しに来ました
と言っても 私も初めから
「答えのない問い」に取り組むのが
大切だとは 分かっていませんでした
私も ほとんどの皆さんと同じように
受験をしてきましたし
中学校を選ぶ際も
偏差値の高い中学校を選びました
それは 私の頭の中で 良い中学校に入れば
良い高校に入れて 良い大学に入れて
そして 良い就職先に就ける
そういう 一つのレールのようなものが
私の頭の中にあったからです
しかし その考えは
中学校の頃に 覆されます
それは ファーストレゴリーグ
との出会いでした
私は 中学生の頃に
ファーストレゴリーグという大会に挑みました
ファーストレゴリーグというのは
国際的なロボットコンテストで
世界的に有名です
もしかしたら 皆さん
ロボットコンテストと聞かれると
『NHKロボコン』のようなものを
想像されるかもしれませんが
ファーストレゴリーグは
それに劣らず もっと画期的で
そして もっと世界中の人々が集まる
楽しい大会なんです
この大会は
ロボットコンテストと言われますが
実はロボットだけじゃないんです
ロボットを 使って 動かして
競技をするだけではなくて
実は もう一つ
自分の研究の成果を発表する
プレゼンテーション部門が存在します
これが 私の言う「答えのない問い」に
挑戦することの重要性を気づかされた
原点と言っても良いのです
研究内容は 非常にシンプルで
お題に沿っていれば 自由なんですね
自分で課題を設定し
そしてそれで解決策を導く
それが 一連の流れでした
私が参加した年のお題は
「Nature's Fury! 」
「自然の猛威」でした
皆さん 自然の猛威と聞かれると
何を想像されますか？
例えば 地震であったり 津波であったり
台風であったり 土砂災害であったり
そういう 自然災害の現象を もしかしたら
頭の中で想像されるかもしれません
しかし その中で 私達は
子供のための「防災教育」に視点を向けて
そして 課題として 今の子供のための
防災教育の不備を設定し
解決策として 防災教育の教材を
開発しようとしたんです
私達は チーム一丸となって
自分達が作る教材が必要になるだろうと
信じて活動していました
もし ファーストレゴリーグという大会が
「答えのない問い」ではなく
「答えのある問い」をお題にしたら
どうしたのかと 考えてみることがあります
そうすると まず 私達のチームのように
意見のぶつかり合いは
起こらなかったと思うんです
なぜなら 「答えのある問い」であれば
いくら意見は大切だと言えども
その意見は 正しいか 正しくないかの
二つに分かれてしまいます
正しくない意見に
わざわざ耳を傾ける必要はないんですね
そしてもう一つ それは
たくさんの面白いアイディアには
触れ合えなかったんだろうなと 思います
実は 私は
このファーストレゴリーグという大会で
世界大会に出場しています
世界中の人々と
競い合うわけなんですけれども
日本とは違って 国や文化の違いもあって
本当に多様なアイディアを
聞くことができました
私は 英語という壁を乗り越えて
積極的にコミュニケーションを取り
自分たちのチームと意見交換をしたり
連絡先を交換して
今でも その海外の子と
連絡を取り合うことがあります
俯瞰して見てみると
この 一つの「答えのない問い」への挑戦が
意見のぶつかり合いを引き起こし
そして 人との交流まで生み出しました
そして何より
これが楽しいと 気づけたのです
ファーストレゴリーグに参加する前は
私も受験で 知識を詰め込む毎日でした
毎日 毎日 椅子に縛られて
勉強したのを覚えています
しかし 実際はどうなんでしょう？
その縛られた紐を緩めて
自分のできることや
好きなことや 没頭できることに
時間を割いてみるのも 良いのではないかと
私は 思っているんです
私は プレゼンテーションや
人前で話すことが好きだから
ファーストレゴリーグという大会に
没頭できたのかもしれません
しかし プレゼンテーションや
ロボットに限った話ではなく
スポーツでも 同じことが言えます
スポーツも
どうやったら明日の試合に勝てるか
なんていう方程式はありません
野球でも
1000回素振りすれば うまくなるか？
明日の試合に勝てるのか？といったら
そうじゃないかもしれないんです
まず 課題を見つけて
自分の弱いところを
他人と比較しながら 自己分析をする
そして 解決策として
先輩やコーチに話を聞きながら
自分の練習方法を確立していく
確立した自分の練習方法を 信じて 貫いて
次の試合に備えること
ぐらいしかできないでしょう
そういう意味で スポーツマンというのは
常に「答えのない問い」に
取り組んでいる人と言えるのです
初めは 「答えのない問い」に取り組む際
何が解決策なのか よくわからなくなります
そして 不安になります
野球でも
走り込みや 筋トレをしたからといって
すぐに実を結ぶものではありません
「答えのない問い」を取り組む際も
なかなか すぐに答えが出てこない
その曖昧さに堪える訓練も必要なんです
いま現在 嬉しいことに
ファーストレゴリーグのような取り組みが
学校現場でも 採用され始めています
それは「SSH」や「SGH」などが
その例にあたります
特に「SSH」は
スーパー サイエンス ハイスクールの略で
高校生のうちから
理系の研究ができる環境が整い始めました
しかし 「SSH」という研究とはいえども
やはり 研究の結果だけにフォーカスする
というような風潮があります
しかし 本当に大切なことはそうじゃないと
私は言いたいのです
その大切なことは
実はこれもファーストレゴリーグ
という大会に参加して気づかされました
ファーストレゴリーグには
「core value」というような
プレゼンテーション競技があります
日本語に訳すと 「core」が「核」
「value」が「価値」
「核となる価値」です
ファーストレゴリーグで
最も対戦されている
プレゼンテーション競技の
一つなんですけれども
ここでは チームワークについて
競い合います
自分のチームで 問題が発生したときに
「どのようにして解決しましたか」
というものをお話しするんです
ここで私が言いたいのは
研究の結果だけじゃなくて
重要なのは そのプロセスなんだと
そこに至るまでのプロセスが大事で
そしてそれは まさに
「答えのない問い」だということです
チームワークに関しては
まさに 答えがない典型だと思います
私もリーダーを務めたことがあって
中学生の頃は よく本屋さんへ行って
自己啓発の本を読み漁りました
自分は どうやったら 10人の
チームメンバーをまとめられるんだろう？
リーダーって何なんだろう？
ということを考えさせられました
本を読んでみるのは 良いんですけども
著者によって 考え方が違うんですね
だから自分でも
どうすれば良いんだろうと考えて
心も病みかけることもありました
ずばりまさに これが
「答えのない問い」だったんです
私達は 社会に出るための準備として
学校に通います
しかし 本当に必要な学習というのは
実は 机の上で収まり切らないん
じゃないでしょうか？
それに 一刻も早く気づければ
自分の興味のあることや
好きなことに没頭して
そして研究をして取り組んでみる
それだけでも また違う
今とは違う世界を楽しめるはずなんです
私が「答えのない問い」に取り組み始めて
もう一つ 気づいたことがあります
それは 自分を信じることです
私は 「答えのない問い」への挑戦として
プロジェクションマッピングという
映像技術の研究を行いました
プロジェクションマッピングは
高度な映像技術です
私は 東京駅の
プロジェクションマッピングを見たときに
ぜひ 自分の手で
このプロジェクションマッピングを
作ってみたいと思ったんですね
当時のプロジェクションマッピングは
お客さんを楽しませる
エンターテイメント中心のものが
多かったのです
ですから 私は そうではなくて
何か教育用の教材として 作れないかなと
プロジェクションマッピングを
利用できないかなと考えたんです
そのとき ふと頭に思い浮かんだのは
小学校や中学校の頃に学んだ
体の授業でした
体の授業の際に 私達の先生は
人体模型を使っていたのですが
人体模型を使うより
プロジェクションマッピングという
映像技術を使って
心臓のリアルな動きであったり
血管の動きであったり
神経の流れであったり
そういうことを再現できれば
子供ももっと楽しめる授業になるのでは
ないかと考えて研究を始めました
しかし 大きな壁にぶち当たったんです
基本中の基本なのですが
体に映すための映像の素材を
見つけることが できなかったんです
いくら動画サイトを探っても
なかなか リアルな心臓の動きを
見つけることはできなかった
そこで私は 神戸大学の教授とアポを取り
facebookでつながって
そして 実際に神戸大学に出向き
映像の素材を得られました
そこで 何もかも
うまくいったように思えたんです
映像の素材もゲットできたことですし
けど 実際はそうではありませんでした
それからの研究は なかなか
うまく進むことがなかったんです
なぜ 研究がうまく
いかなかったんでしょうか？
[落とし穴]
それは 私が答えを探し求めるあまり
自分の個性を生かしきれていなかったのです
リアルな映像技術が なかったらなかったで
もっと 自分にできることを
考えてみるべきでした
「答えのない問い」に取り組む中でも
大事なことは 私がこの経験を通して感じた
置かれた状況で
いかにして自分の個性を生かすか
自分で解決策を導くか
答えを探し求めるだけでは
いけないということです
「答えのない問い」に取り組むのは
時に リスクを背負うことになりますし
答えがないからこそ 不安になり
答えを探しがちになりますが
探すのではなくて 自分の力や
今まで培ってきた個性を信じて
自分だけのオリジナルを作る
そういった意識が必要なのです
実際 私の身体のマッピングは
うまくいくことはありませんでした
しかし だからといって諦めずに
原点に立ち返ってみることにしたのです
身体のマッピングより より規模の小さい
マッピングを作ることにしました
その中でも 私が大事にしたのは
自分だけのオリジナルの
作品を作るという意識です
今ではその努力が実り
社会貢献をすることができています
これは 福祉関連のオフィスで
実際に障害を持った子供達に
楽しんでもらった
プロジェクションマッピングの一部です
私は ファーストレゴリーグで学んできた
「答えのない問い」に取り組む大切さを
プロジェクションマッピングの研究でも
実感してきたわけですが
「答えのない問い」に取り組むことの真骨頂は
自分の可能性を広げることに
あるのだと考えています
自分にできることは —
きっと大きいことはできません
しかし 小さいことでも良いから
何か課題設定をしてみて 解決策を導いてみる
私の研究も マッピングだけにとどまらず
ロボットの講習会を行い
一人でも多くの子供達に
ファーストレゴリーグのような
経験をしてもらいたい
そして 「答えのない問い」への大切さを
知ってもらいたいと 考えています
大きなことでなくても 小さなことから
積み上げてみませんか？
皆さんもぜひ「答えのない問い」への
挑戦をしてみてはいかがでしょうか？
ありがとうございました
（拍手）